hey everybody welcome back to the
channel in today's video we're going to
be talking about purchasing land for
your homestead and I got three things
that you need to look out for if you're
a beginner just starting out trying to
find your dream property so let's get to
it all right first thing I hey well
first of all I'm back here in the back
40 as I call it um back here where I do
my hunting at got my redneck blind back
there um this was something that was
important to me but we'll get to that in
just a second first let's talk about
location all right location location
location for me location meant you know
I was in uh Washington State when I
finished my military career and um I
that's growing Zone 8 well was 88 at the
time and um I felt like I love that
growing zone so I wanted to have my
forever property in growing zone 8 as
well so that was something that I looked
for I like growing zone 8 because I can
grow all year round and it's it's
probably
the the zone that I think is most most
universal for being able to grow all
year round um the Summers get hot but
they don't get as hot as N9 and 10 and
11 you know um but the winters are mild
so they don't get as cold as seven you
know six and five and four um so I have
a really long growing season I can
definitely grow 365 days a year um and
that's something that was important to
me so that's why location location
location is so important so for
me uh as far as location is concerned
that was really that was really it that
was all that I was really concerned
about um but you know some people may
want to be close to family some people
may not want to be close to family you
know what I mean so you know I wanted to
be I guess you could say uh close enough
that if I had to get home on an
emergency I can do it
but I'm far enough away where I ain't
got to worry about somebody coming
knocking on the door if you know what I
mean so so location is super super super
important all right so something that I
um also had in mind was your local
resources or your community um I feel
that for a homesteader especially first
starting off you really need
to um look at what's in your area that
you can use so um stuff
like like resources like feed for your
animals so important right um I know
most every place you know you got ATT
track the supply or you got this or you
got you know feed store or whatever but
um you know look at those places and
make sure that you have the type of
place that
you are going to make a long-term
commitment to as far as uh where you're
going to be purchasing from because a
lot of places just don't have the things
that you may have had in your last
location so
definitely um what you know look at what
is in your community as far as resources
you know can you get compost bulk you
know or do you have to buy bag compost
um you know bag compost gets expensive
you know uh but some people you know
that's all they need and so you know way
your weigh your your needs and your
wants and determine whether or not
you're going to need stuff like you know
bulk things that can be delivered to you
because some places hey I'm going tell
you it's nice to live off grid it's not
it's nice to to not um have neighbors or
whatever sometimes you know but
sometimes it's nice to have a neighbor
or two you know sometimes it's nice to
be able to head out to the feed store
and only have to drive you know 15 20
minutes versus 2 hours to get feed for
your animals you know what I mean so
that's something that's very very very
important and often overlooked is what
you
can what you can locally just reach out
and get in a in a in a pinch um some
things yeah you can plan it out and
where you can get it delivered to you or
whatever but that's extra cost as well
so definitely your local resources is
something that I highly recommend that
you look into especially if you're
buying a property that you want a
homestead on also when you're looking at
uh your local resources you know you you
want to make sure that you have access
to agricultural resources as far as like
nrcs or um your your a extensions and
stuff like that um make sure that you
know cuz like let's take for instance me
right and um I'm not bad mouthing
anybody or whatever this is something
that they told me you know so my
County's um a extension is not doesn't
have a lot of
uh of resources I would say and they
have even pointed me to you know a
sister County that has better resources
because they have uh a ug extension over
there so University of Georgia extension
so um it's a little further drive you
know but it's not too too bad but that's
something that I didn't know prior to
buying this property versus you know my
extension office is you know six 6 to 10
minutes away you know so um
definitely um you know having to go and
drive 30 minutes to the other extension
office is not ideal um it's probably not
something that I would have uh like not
bought the property over but you know
you have to look into those kinds of
things as well and last but not least um
the property condition and so what I
mean by that there's a lot that goes
into that um like me I knew I was going
to be having Gardens and whatnot and I
wanted to grow on this property so I
asked the the seller if I could do a
soil test they had no issue with me
doing a soil test cuz they knew that
they had you know premium soil here I
mean this soil they had horses here at
one point and this soil is just it's
Immaculate I did a soil test and
um it told me that I don't need to add
anything to the soil just grow in it you
know so um you don't run into that too
often not that I would have uh said hey
I'm not going to buy the property
because of the soil test um but I would
like to know what I'm getting into you
know from the soil test the other thing
that was really important to me was you
know I want to be on well water I don't
want to be on City water so um I made
sure and I I saw that before I even came
to the property that it was on well
water so well water was important to me
um it may not be important to you so but
that is something cuz you know I don't
have a water bill and I use a lot of
water here on my property so um that's
something to definitely take into
consideration when you're uh starting
off homesteading everything needs water
your animal your plants everything you
everything needs water so definitely
don't overlook that and if you can shave
off a little bit of your monthly bill by
having a well or if you have the ability
to dig a well uh because they dug a well
here on the backside of the property and
I have a well for the houses as well so
um you know that kind of thing is super
super important when you're talking
about infrastructure for your animals
you know if if you want you know know a
readymade place that already has Barns
and and uh fencing and all that kind of
stuff that's something you need to be
looking for don't overlook it don't
think oh I could just build that later
because you'll be four five six years
later and you still don't have a fence
you know I may be talking about myself
but
hey but no for uh but something that I
did not look at though I would say this
is a mistake that I made Okay so when I
pulled up onto the property uh the house
is kind of higher than the road right so
you know and that's typical cuz you want
your grade to go away from the house um
and then when I came back here to the
back I noticed that everything slopes
down back here and there's a there's
a a river not a river but a creek a
stream that runs through back there um
so so I figured okay yeah everything
goes down downhill toward you know water
typically and so I looked at it and I
was like okay that's cool that's that's
what I wanted that's what I want but
something you know I looked at the soil
I looked at the slope I looked at
everything you know I I like the slope
too cuz I was like man so I don't have
to worry about having one of those mud
Farms you know what I'm saying cuz you
know everybody everybody talks about
those mud Farms man I didn't want one of
those so I was like you know being on a
slope like this the water going to run
off and I'm not going to have standing
water and I don't you know but I didn't
think about
why why the Topography of my land was or
is the way it is I didn't think about
that and
so you know you get to working and you
get to doing stuff and next thing you
know it's like dang everywhere I dig
there's rocks and I got my yard my front
yard done I got it leveled when I first
moved here and um you know I I I had a a
company come in and kind of grade it
because I couldn't cut it because there
were so many rocks that were like um you
know I had to mow around rocks and stuff
you know so I was like a man I like to
mow you know I like to mow my yard so I
was like hey I need y'all to come in
here and get these rocks out of here and
hey they got the rocks out so you know I
was like all right cool so y'all got the
rocks out but he couldn't get it as
level as I wanted it to be you know and
so uh he was like man man you got some
huge rocks in this ground and I was like
what he was like yeah man you got rocks
so big that like you probably need
Dynamite to like to like dislodge him
you know he said you probably your house
is probably sitting on a big rock you
know and I was like ah so right around
the street the um the uh the next little
town over or whatever it's not really a
town it's just it don't really have
nothing over there but um it's called
The Rock The Rock Georgia you know so so
it makes sense you know and as as you're
driving by and you see other people's
houses and stuff you see a lot of rocks
like big rocks in their yards you know
whatnot so that's something that I did
not take into consideration so when I'm
making my Gardens and whatnot I tend to
hit rocks and I don't mean just little
rocks I mean big boulders that I hit
that I have to either grow around try to
dig up some of them I've been able to
dig up but I mean I got rocks that are
like you know big big as people you know
what I mean so like you can't just dig
those things up especially with me I
don't have any um equipment like that I
just have my hands my shovel and whatnot
to to get that kind of stuff up so I'm
able to get some of them up but for the
most part they I have to work around
them you know so um that is definitely
something that I was like okay yeah I I
messed up when it came to that now if I
had known that would I have still
purchased the property yes yes I would I
I love this property I mean I absolutely
love it it has a a healing feeling to it
and I don't know if you understand what
I mean by that but it it's the type of
place that when you come to it you just
get uh amazing energy from it and man it
seems like everything that I do here
like succeeds you know so um yeah I
wouldn't I wouldn't trade this property
for anything what I am going to do um
eventually is
my my uh stand is going to be moved to a
different property um probably in the
next three or four years uh where I will
have a hunting property and then I can
change everything back here to Growing
I'm already growing my um Orchard back
there I can also grow you know corn or
you know wheat or something back there
as well so that's my three things that I
think that um you know every beginner
Homesteader that's looking to purchase
property really needs to be looking at
um the
location the amenities or the resources
around that location and the condition
of the property um you may even be
looking at those things and like me I
was looking at the soil you know I was
checking the soil out I was checking out
the conditions the the Topography of the
of the land but I didn't take into
consideration the big old rocks that
they have here and I mean when you're
doing anything you putting up posts you
doing anything anything you have to dig
into the ground um it's tough when you
got big boulders that you have to deal
with uh but the good thing about rocks
is if you get one that's deep enough
it's a good support you know so you can
you can put a post on on top of it you
know that post is never going to sink so
you you can use it for for good you know
um or uh find the good in it I guess you
could say but hey that's my three tips
that's the three things that I think
that you really need to focus on um hey
if I missed anything definitely get down
in the comments let me know uh you know
if you're a season Homestead or and you
maybe you've bought a couple Properties
or whatnot definitely let me know if
there were some things that you would
have added into this list um obviously
it's a short list just three items but
within those three items I think there's
a lot there's a lot to uh unpack in
those three uh categories that that I
um those three categories that I feel
are very very very important to the uh
beginning Homesteader all right well
that's it I really appreciate you guys
uh hanging in there with me and um hey
make sure you do all the YouTube stuff
make sure you uh like share subscribe
and uh hey I'll see you in the next
video